[Music]
ah man is cold you are special agent
lance sterling oh okay okay everybody
good
I'm just gonna take his gun and I'm
gonna toss it to that snowman and while
you're both looking all confused trying
to figure out what's going on I'm just
gonna knock you out
[Music]
II didn't deserve that rats with wings
I'm in position
what is your situation
just getting a visual me now
[Music]
ten o'clock katsu Kimora everybody's
favorite arms dealer there that
briefcase is your objective
inside is the LLL not assassin the first
semi-autonomous attack drone powered by
atmospheric energy never shuts down
never stops pursuing its target they
stole it from our covert weapons lab
director Jenkins
he's got incoming detecting seventy
extra hostels around the perimeter
another mess like her cast and Lance
listen to me you've got seventy Yakuza
incoming stand down no do not engage
this time you need to wait for the
backup team her I fly solo
I
it's time to introduce myself
ladies and gentlemen
hard as you can go steady turn it up we
give in the show but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you can tell when you're the
world's greatest spy starting
non-starting everyone knows the name I'm
gonna need that case just three ounces
of pressure to the vagus nerve and then
look at your boy sleepy night-night
hey you mind give me a hand come on was
it the hand for the world's greatest fun
I am way too good at desi ultimate
mission none of our agents can get close
to him for leads the ultimate disguise
science rocks on Christmas Day
a pigeon could make you an even better
spy Will Smith and Tom Holland give me
ten feet Hey no human feet they made you
part of the flaws I don't care that your
name is Jeff our spies in the sky nice
to meet you Jeff
stop talking to [ __ ] BBG
[Music]